what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and we just watched the
third episode of hawkeye and wow
they stepped it up this episode they did
a lot including they introduced kingpin
to the marvel cinematic universe he is
now in the mcu if you did not see him
don't worry i will show you exactly
where they introduced him to if you were
wondering who they were referring to
when they said uncle that's kingpin and
i'll show you exactly what you need to
see in this video so of course we have
to talk about daredevil since they
introduced kingpin what is daredevil
coming to the mcu we learned a lot about
echo and i'm going to break her story
down including some changes they made
from the comics and of course we gotta
talk about kate bishop and hawkeye so a
lot to break down in this video i have a
few theories on what could actually be
happening and of course i'm going to
explain that ending there with jack so
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any future hawkeye breakdowns or
theories now at the end of hawkeye
episode 2 we were introduced to a woman
believed to be the boss of the tracksuit
mafia if you caught my last breakdown
about episode 2 you know that this is
maya lopez aka echo and we learn a
little bit about her backstory in the
beginning of episode three we see her in
class and it's very clear that she is
deaf however her teacher and i'm
assuming the students around her as well
do not realize that she is deaf in fact
her teacher thinks that she's not paying
attention when in reality she just
simply can't hear she can only read the
teacher's lips but she's very very smart
and we see this when the teacher goes
over to her to try and correct her and
tell her to pay attention but the
teacher soon realizes that maya is
paying attention and she's getting all
the answers right in this book now one
of the things to fill out in this book
says when i'm playing tag i run as fast
as a dragon this leads us into the next
scene with her father her and her father
are having some fun and they make it
very very clear here that she is deaf
maya then asks her father in american
sign language if dragons are real and it
really seems like her father may
actually know something that went on
with xiang chi or maybe at least knows
about tallow the ancient hidden city
where the dragon actually is because he
says maybe they're real but if they are
they are existing in another world which
tallow technically is in another realm
in fact in chongqi they make it pretty
clear that talo is indeed a different
world in a different realm and he goes
on to tell maya that he's sorry but he
can't send her to a deaf school so she's
going to have to go to a normal school
and he tells his daughter that she's
going to have to jump between worlds
kind of like the dragons do so maybe her
father actually knows a little bit now
you can see in the background that
maya's won an achievement in some type
of martial art we then cut to a scene
where she is indeed at a karate academy
and this is where we finally see kingpin
maya's dad goes up to her and says be
good in class today and then he tells
her that it's more about speed than size
which she will soon use to her advantage
to take down a kid who is much bigger
than her but before he leaves he says
uncle will take you home and we see a
huge figure show up wearing an all black
suit and he grabs her by the cheek and
she smiles and we hear a laugh from him
now this is clearly kingpin however the
question is is vincent d'onofrio
returning to play kingpin he played him
in the daredevil series and there have
been rumors that dinofrio would return
to play kingpin along with charlie cox
returning to play matt murdock although
they will not be connected to the
characters that they played in the
netflix series so essentially a reboot
of the characters just using the same
actors now i will say that dinofrio has
kind of hinted that he would be
returning in fact he tweeted just a
couple of weeks ago not even on november
17th a quote tweet to marvel studios
tweet the marvel studios tweet said one
week until we hit the mark marvel
studios as hawkeye starts streaming
november 24th on disney plus in which he
quote tweeted this is going to be fun i
love these marvel series his return as
kingpin has been heavily reported and
rumored for a very long time now
specifically for the hawkeye series and
now we have this huge figure that is
referred to as uncle wearing an all
black suit showing up in the hawkeye
series as somebody that is close to maya
and that takes care of her and someone
who has a laugh an awful lot like
dionyfrios now fast forward to when
she's an adult she's spying with
somebody and we notice that she actually
has a prosthetic leg now some people may
think oh she lost her leg somehow
growing up but two things one aliquot
cox who plays echo in this series is an
amputee so this is real and two maya
lopez as a child does have a prosthetic
leg it's very clear to see when the
karate instructor calls her up to fight
the other kid she gets up and you can
see her prosthetic leg so this is just
something cool that they did for alaqua
cox because she's an amputee and she is
also deaf in real life as well and this
is just great inclusion right here by
marvel studios now as we see maya grow
up we can tell that she's become really
skilled at fighting and she pulls up on
a motorcycle to a place called fat man
auto repair really fat man auto repair
they're really telling us right here
that this is kingpin because this place
right here is simply a front for the
tracksuit mafia this is their base their
current base at the time but when she
pulls up ronin is there and he is
cleaning house he is killing everybody
and unfortunately he kills her father as
well ronan kills her father right as she
walks in and she runs to his aid and
runs and leaves as he dies she holds him
in her arms and he tells her to fly away
like a little dragon calling back to the
conversation that they had when she was
a little child before he dies he puts
his hand on her face and when he dies
his hand falls off but leaves a hand
print made out of blood on her face now
here's what you need to know about ekko
kingpin and daredevil from the comics
unfortunately maya's father actually
dies in the comics as well but it's
actually kind of weird in the comics
kingpin actually kills her father
however she is kind of unaware of this
and with her father's dying last words
he asked kingpin to raise his daughter
properly so that's exactly what kingpin
does he raises her almost like an uncle
would which is why we get the uncool
kingpin in this now when her father dies
in the comics he also leaves a bloody
handprint on her face and when she grows
up she works for kingpin and kingpin
sends her to prove matt murdock's
weakness kingpin tells her that matt
murdock believes fisk is a bad person
and that she is the only person who can
convince matt that he's wrong now at
this point in time she actually believes
wilson fisk aka kingpin is a good person
so she technically isn't lying to him
she eventually falls in love with matt
murdock not knowing that he's daredevil
but soon enough she takes on the echo
guys and she goes to hunt down daredevil
and on her face she paints a white
handprint that symbolizes the bloody
handprint that her father left on her
now eventually she finds out that
daredevil and matt murdock are indeed
the same person and from there matt
murdock tells her all about kingpin and
she comes to the realization that
kingpin is indeed a bad person now
ultimately in the comics she would go on
to shoot him in the face and he would go
blind however later on he would go on to
recover his sight and they basically are
setting all of this up right now in the
hawkeye series echo has her own disney
plus series coming it's been announced
and guess who has been reported to be
appearing in the echo series both
kingpin and daredevil and well we saw
kingpin in this episode so he's
definitely confirmed for the show which
means that daredevil is most likely
confirmed as well with him scheduled to
make his mcu debut in spider-man no way
home so that is super awesome we have
kingpin in the mcu now and hopefully
matt murdock aka daredevil soon but what
exactly is happening here in the hawkeye
series i have a theory in this episode
we see that ronin aka hawkeye killed
maya's father however i don't think that
was actually hawkeye unfortunately
maya's father was wearing a tracksuit so
of course he would think that he's part
of the tracksuit mafia but hawkeye even
as ronan didn't just go around killing
innocent people and maya's father didn't
really seem like a bad person kind of
just a person down on his luck who
needed some money and kingpin was there
to offer some but here's the thing we
have no idea when the death of maya's
father by ronan or the person we think
is rodent took place yes it could have
happened in that five year gap when
hawkeye was ronin after all hawkeye does
know a lot about the tracksuit mafia but
it could have also happened when hawkeye
did not have the ronin suit and somebody
else could have put it on and taken out
the tracksuit mafia or at least tried to
take out a lot of them it actually could
have been jack kate's mother's fiance in
the comics jack is swordsman a mentor to
hawkeye now swordsman would be a villain
in the comics but eventually would go on
to be an avenger and yes he does like
swords a lot in the mcu and yes he could
have actually been the one to take out
the tracksuit mafia in that scene
however i think it's so in our face
about jack being somewhat of a bad guy
that it's a little bit too obvious which
makes me believe that he's probably not
a villain yeah he's up to some shady
stuff but i'm not sure that he's a
killer but what could be happening is
that kingpin could have actually hired
somebody to do some killings for him
it's definitely not unheard of of a mob
boss to kill his own men however if you
don't want people knowing that you
killed your own men you hire somebody
else to do it and in a world where
there's this person named ronan going
around all massed up and suited up
killing mafias and mobsters what better
way to disguise you killing your own
people than to get somebody to dress up
as ronin then again it could have
actually been hawkeye and that's
something that hawkeye and ekko are
going to have to face in this series
however right now i do kind of feel like
it's not hawkeye who actually killed her
now in this episode we get a lot of
answers to questions that we had from
the last two the biggest one being why
does ekko in the tracksuit mafia want
ronin and hawkeye and kate bishop but
not really we learned that what they
really want is ronin ekko wants the
person responsible for killing her
father and of course attracting mafia
wants the person responsible for killing
some of their men we realize that ekko
only wants kate bishop because she
believes that kate bishop is ronan
however hawkeye pretty much convinces
her that kate's not ronan she's a little
girl a nine-year-old as he calls her now
here we see more of the bickering and
bantering between kate bishop and
hawkeye much like in the mad fraction
run echo tells hawkeye that he might
find that he's better off without his
hearing aid and then clint looks like
kate and says yeah you might be right
about that one now clint explains that
she put on the suit by accident she
didn't know what it was she didn't know
what it meant she's not ronin and
ronan's not back now echo doesn't really
bite that and says that just because
she's not ronin doesn't mean that
ronan's not back however clint makes up
a story and says that the ronin isn't
back because ronan is dead and black
widow killed him obviously he's not
trying to tell her that he is ronan
because he doesn't want the heat for
that and since black widow is dead it's
easy enough to say that she killed him
and in a way she actually did when
hawkeye was ronin black widow was the
person that brought him back in a way
she killed ronin and brought back clint
now maya's so upset about ronin killing
her father and she just wants revenge
that she actually goes to choke kate out
she doesn't really believe anything that
they are telling her and believes that
kate is ronin however quasi stops her
and that gives clint just enough time to
escape and from here we get some really
awesome hand-to-hand combat between maya
and clint clint goes to hit maya with a
hockey stick but then she puts up her
metal prosthetic leg and it deflects it
she then uses that leg to kick clint in
the head which is obviously a very big
blow being made out of metal or
something similar to it and it almost
knocks him out but it does knock out his
hearing aid in which she steps on to
destroy it now hawkeye eventually gets
his hand on his bow and arrows and maya
actually picks up kate's bow and hawkeye
in true falling hawkeye fashion shoots
an arrow and releases kate from the duct
tape that's around her wrist she gets
loose and then she fights qazi and
absolutely kicks his butt we see how
strong and skilled kate really is from
here we get to see hawkeye in his true
element shooting arrows in a truly
awesome scene eventually kate and
hawkeye leave and they go outside to get
a car to make a getaway in which kate
says can we take this one and hawkeye
says i'm not smashing a 72 challenger
come on and this is actually taken from
the comics hawkeye's dream car is a
challenger from the 1970s in fact in
this comic strip right here he says
that's the most beautiful ride i ever
seen 1970 dodge challenger man i always
wanted one of these and i love that
they're sticking true to hawkeye's love
for the challenger and that he won't
smash it because he loves it so much now
from here they take off trying to outrun
the tracksuit mafia whose front is now
trust a bro moving company and they do
say bro a lot so that's pretty clever
and this is where kate gets to show off
her archery skills to hawkeye however
hawkeye restricts the arrows that she's
going to use because they are too
dangerous but from here we actually see
a lot of classic hawkeye arrows that are
used in the comics the first one that
kate shoots what she calls a play-doh
arrow is actually a putty arrow that
hawkeye uses now hawkeye is actually
telling her which arrows to use but
unfortunately since his hearing aid was
damaged and he can no longer use it he
can't actually hear what she's saying
and what she's saying is they're not
labeled she doesn't know which ones they
are so unfortunately she's kind of just
grabbing and firing now the next arrow
she shoots would actually just be a
regular explosive arrow and hawkeye
removed four arrows saying that they
were too dangerous so you gotta wonder
what those other arrows were if they
were more dangerous than an explosive
arrow the next one she shoots is a
suction tip arrow in which she questions
what's the purpose for it the purpose
would later on be revealed when hawkeye
grabs her and saves them both by
sticking the suction cup arrow to a
train saving their lives the next arrow
she shoots is a cable arrow that shoots
a bunch of different cables out and
luckily for her the cables grab a bunch
of christmas trees and stop the truck
from going after them the next arrows
are actually given to her by hawkeye and
they are acid arrows and he tells her to
shoot out the stop lights we presume
that this is so he could cross the
street without having to deal with
oncoming traffic now echo eventually
catches up to them in the challenger and
it gets close enough for kate to get her
bow back but unfortunately she shoots
one of hawkeye's heirs into the dash and
this is either a smoke bomb era which i
believe that it is or a tear gas arrow
now i'm pretty sure it's just a smoke
arrow and the smoke that comes out is
purple because that's the color of
hawkeye and k bishop and hawkeye has
said that the challenger got totaled
anyways and he probably was thinking i
should have just taken the car myself
now from here kate and hawkeye get stuck
on the bridge and they realize that the
truck is just going to run into them and
here we get possibly the coolest scene
of the episode and the series so far
hawkeye gives kate a normal arrow and
tells her to shoot up she doesn't know
what the plan is but then we see hawkeye
pull out a arrow that has a pym particle
head on it and it's also glowing blue
she shoots the arrow up and he hits the
arrow with the pim era which clearly has
pin particles in it that allow the arrow
to enlarge much like ant-man is able to
become giant man and i'm gonna argue
that this is the coolest scene so far
now here clint realizes that he is going
to need the suction arrow because
they're going to have to jump off the
bridge and it gives a usb arrow to kate
telling her to cover him now we've seen
the usb arrow before we saw him use it
in the very first avengers film he used
it to hack into the hello carrier
unfortunately it can't really do any
damage to anybody so kate has to kind of
bluff hawkeye gets the suction arrow but
unfortunately kate gets really nervous
and lets loose the usb arrow revealing
that it does nothing so her and hawkeye
jump off the bridge in true hawkeye
fashion the same jump that she saw
hawkeye do when she was just a little
kid in 2012 when he saved her life and
now she gets to do it with him you
notice that she actually grabs onto his
boat because she knows exactly what he's
going to do because she saw him do it
before hawkeye shoots the cable arrow
and they both swing onto the train
underneath the bridge and he uses the
suction tip arrow to stop them and save
them now from here they get on the
subway and keep in mind clint still
can't hear because his hearing aid is
still damaged however kate keeps
forgetting this or she just hasn't
grasped it yet she starts talking about
how she should probably walk the dog but
hawkeye can't hear her and he speaks his
mind saying that you're not wrong you
probably are one of the greatest archers
because she just showed how good of an
archer she was so hawkeye is clearly
impressed here of course kate starts
freaking out but hawkeye again can't
hear her and then he states that she
should probably walk the dog this is
showing us that even though hawkeye and
kate are kind of bickering and bantering
with each other they are kind of on the
same level they're starting to click and
get in tune with each other now here's
where things kind of get pretty
emotional without hawkeye's hearing aid
he is pretty much fully death and we
find him and kate and lucky the pizza
dog back at aunt myra's apartment
hawkeye gets a call from who he believes
to be his wife but it is actually
nathaniel and he figures this out with
the help of kate he can't hear anything
so kate translates everything for him
using a notepad and here we see that
hawkeye is missing out on all the
christmas traditions that the kids want
to do and he doesn't really know when
he's going to get back or if he's
actually going to make it back in time
for christmas and we could possibly get
a little bit of foreshadowing here his
youngest son nathaniel says that it's
okay if he doesn't make it back for
christmas and i hate to say it but this
could be foreshadowing clint's death a
lot of people are after him right now we
have ekko the tracksuit mafia and of
course elena balova the sister of black
widow who thinks clint killed black
widow is coming for him as well now i
really really hope they don't kill off
clint i really hope they don't but it is
a possibility unfortunately now here the
tracksuit mafia has to leave because
their cover has kind of been blown if
you notice they have a lot of stuffed
animals this is most likely because they
are keeping their guns and or drugs
inside of these stuffed animals but
kasia wants to talk to maya because she
almost killed kate and qazi thinks that
got a little bit out of hand now here we
find out two things one uncle who of
course is kingpin wouldn't like them
going after ronan and two her father was
in charge before her so he was clearly
somewhat high with the tracksuit mafia
working for kingpin probably since
kingpin was referred to as maya's uncle
but the fact that kingpin wouldn't want
the tracksuit mafia going after ronin
leads me to believe that perhaps kingpin
was behind ronin in some way like i
mentioned in the beginning perhaps ronan
wasn't actually hawkeye but somebody
else but here we do see that maya is
dead set on finding ronin so she can get
revenge for her father's death mai ends
the conversation by telling qazi to look
into clint barton meanwhile kate and
hawkeye are waiting for somebody who can
fix his hearing aid while he cannot hear
her she sends him a text saying good
thing they call you hawkeye and not hawk
ear and you truly do start to appreciate
this quirky relationship that they have
with each other hawkeye jokingly says
block and delete clint gets his hearing
aid fixed and the two of them go have
breakfast this is where kate tells clint
that she's been dreaming of this moment
her entire life becoming a superhero and
clinton starts to tell her that it comes
with a lot of sacrifices and of course
natasha is probably who he's thinking
about especially when he says and some
things you'll lose forever and of course
sacrifices he's obviously thinking about
his family as well right now he's
sacrificing christmas with his family
but she's kind of giving him hope saying
that there's also some things that you
gain and from here we actually see her
draw a new costume for hawkeye which is
actually his comic accurate costume and
i really really love how they do this
and i wouldn't be surprised if he wears
this by the end of the show now
unfortunately to kate hawkeye says he's
not a role model to anyone this is
because he's thinking of himself as
ronan murdering a bunch of people but of
course he is a role model to kate he's
been her hero since he saved her life in
2012. hawkeye tells kate that she has to
name the dog in which she falls upon a
pizza dog and of course in the comics
that's his name lucky the pizza dog
because he loves pizza which we've
already seen now from here hawkeye tells
kate a little bit about the tracksuit
mafia and this is where we learn a
little bit more about kingpin he says
that the guy at the top he will do
anything to grow the operation and
hawkeye makes it clear that there is
somebody above maya now in the comics
the tracksuit mafia and kazi are funded
and ran by kingpin so as you can see and
as i've been stating everything points
to kingpin being in charge and taka even
says it's someone you don't want to mess
with and he explains the bad blood with
ronin slash himself ronin hit the
supplier on the other side and then hit
tracksuit upper management which is why
the tracksuit mafia wants ronin now kate
and clint go to kate's mom's penthouse
because they can use her security
programming that she has there and they
find out that qazi is a current employee
of her mother's company backing up the
theory that her mother is probably evil
and could actually be madame mask which
i'm guessing is going to start to be
revealed in the next episode now clint
starts walking around because as you can
tell by the look on his face he kind of
suspects something is up kate gets
kicked out of the programming that she's
in the account gets disabled and hawkeye
runs into jack with jack raising the
ronin sword to his throat telling him to
stop which is a certain type of irony
now in the comics jack or jacquez is
actually the mentor to hawkeye when they
are in the circus together jack hayes
actually teaches hawkeye how to use
swords now i'm not sure they're going to
go that route in the mcu however i'm
betting that they know each other
somehow and that's something that we're
going to be seeing in the next episode
in the very beginning so a lot happened
in episode 3 the major thing being
kingpin has been introduced and it looks
like he is at the very top of the
tracksuit mafia so let me know your
thoughts about all of this and let me
know what you would rate hawkeye episode
3 1 out of 10 in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos especially
hawkeye videos for live updates you can
always follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof